[Music]
should we be getting vaccinated again
what protection does another booster
vaccination offer against new variants
welcome to the latest edition of our
covid19 special
[Music]
also on the programme in spain medical
experts are concerned that if not enough
people get vaccinated worldwide the
greater the risk that new variants will
emerge
but first to germany
what side effects can covid vaccinations
cause
and where can those affected find help
hello hello doctor
how are you
oh pretty good so far if it weren't for
my elements my lymph nodes under my
armpits are always swollen in the
evening which is new and i've got fluid
retention in my legs but i've had that
for a while
twice a week marc gildmacher goes for
oxygen therapy
the 45 year old from bielefeld is
seriously ill
since his second corona vaccination in
june last year he's developed a range of
symptoms some of them life-threatening
the so-called post-vaccine syndrome is a
newly identified multifaceted condition
for which there are no studies or
treatment guidelines in germany
the treatment here is mark's own
personal attempt to ease his suffering
it won't cure him but it promises to
improve his resilience and ability to
recuperate
the impact
is huge but it's not as easy to diagnose
as known diseases
we're not experts in epidemiology
at first we had to learn how to handle
the pandemic
find the right measures
discover what's appropriate and what's
not
makes it hard for him to climb stairs he
used to be passionate about sports and
played soccer at a local club went
running and did mountain bike tours
until his symptoms made it impossible
that was really a great tour the weather
was super it was really fun
you can see how happy i looked
in my condition now i can't do any of
that
and i don't even know if it will be
possible again
i'm just hoping for the best yeah
it also does best
that mark geldmarker's condition has
been caused by the vaccination has been
medically attested to and his long list
of ailments speaks for itself
his blood vessels are damaged so is his
heart he's in severe pain has
concentration and circulation problems
the list goes on and on he's been on
sick leave since october last year
mark receives a lot of support both in
his private life as well as from work
colleagues his friends are shocked by
what has happened to him
yeah the elan field the pep is missing
the drive is missing
he's not going anymore
when we invite him for a drink after
practice
to have a beer or even a soda
he doesn't want to
he just doesn't have the energy anymore
until 14 or 15 months ago he was still
always active
i'm so sorry that something like this
has happened to him
we want you back to how you were before
to how we loved and valued you
it's really good that i have the guys
that i can have a chat about things and
get support
because otherwise i'd be very very alone
with my problems
there are currently only a few places in
germany where patients can turn to for
help like at the university hospital in
marburg
cardiologist bandhan shiva is one of the
leading physicians treating this
condition
[Music]
the complexity of the symptoms is
actually similar to that found in
long-covered patients
that is the symptomatology changes over
time
that makes it difficult to establish a
diagnosis diagnostic
we treat the associated infections
we put them on a histamine-free diet to
boost the immune system
actually the microbiome at the center of
the immune system
like blood pressure and diabetes and all
the things that were unknown in each
patient up to that point
the fundamental lack of information
means doctors often research
covet-related symptoms for themselves
and develop their own methods for
treatment
this is exactly what ane katrin begaman
did
together with a colleague from berlin
and other doctors from german-speaking
countries she has put together a medical
handbook
[Music]
we are a large group of physicians and
scientists from other fields who have
ideas about this problem
and we've brought those ideas together
in one document
where we also made sure however that we
could give as much evidence as possible
for everything that we wrote in there
so that it's easy for everyone who reads
it to understand how we came up with the
ideas
yeah
and that the treatment we suggest is
evidence-based
i think this is a
hat
bergamot speaks from experience she's
also living with post-vaccine syndrome
the 46 year old has been unable to work
since last fall she suffered from severe
exhaustion for weeks and could hardly
get out of bed in the beginning she
found it hard to manage her symptoms but
now she's feeling better would she get
the covert vaccine again
when he
if i could see that there was now a
development in dealing with the problem
after the vaccination i could imagine
getting vaccinated again
but right now to be honest because i
haven't really had any help
except of course the fantastic help of
my family doctor and my allergist i
would steer clear of it at the moment
the paul ellis institute is responsible
for the safety of vaccines in germany
it recently announced it was conducting
a study on vaccine side effects together
with the hanover medical school
it's an important step for
post-vaccination sufferers like mark
geldmacher and anna katrine bergemann
who hope that researchers might discover
the cause of their problem so that they
and others can finally get help
[Music]
180 million vaccine doses have been
administered in germany how many
recipients have suffered from
complications the paul erlich institute
mentioned in the previous report is
responsible for monitoring the safety of
vaccines in germany our reporter
stefanitzel will talk to its president
klaus
to find out more
how does the paul ellis institute
respond to reports of suspected cases of
side effects
we handle all reports of suspected cases
of vaccine side effects or complications
in the same way
the data is anonymized and evaluated
the suspected cases are reported by
doctors the drug commission vaccine
manufacturers and affected people
firstly we check if these are
identifiable cases of rare or very rare
side effects or whether it's a
coincidence that the reactions have
taken place after getting a particular
vaccine
and to reduce the risks and this is the
aim of this exercise we take measures or
have measures taken
but fundamentally i can say that we're
lucky that the covet vaccines that have
been approved for use in germany in
europe are very safe
that means that we have fewer than 10
recognized cases of severe side effects
for 100 000 vaccinations
that's a very good ratio
and we know on the basis of the many
vaccinations that have now taken place
globally not just in germany or europe
that we have a very good overview of
even the most minor side effects linked
to certain vaccines
and we have acted very quickly either
with the powell early institute itself
or in conjunction with the standing
committee on vaccination or the european
medicines agency to take measures to
further reduce the risks
can you already put a figure on it when
so many suspected cases have already
been reported and when more may be
reported and require investigation
from many of these vaccinations up to
billions of vaccinations have already
taken place
globally they have also now been taking
place over a considerable length of time
over years and we have learned an awful
lot about the vaccines and even about
very rare side effects which purely
statistically cannot be collected even
in very big clinical trials
so we can specify a clear rate of
certain side effects being reported
and they're explained and described in
detail in our periodic safety reports
the typical severe side effects
identified up to now are myocarditis and
pericarditis in the case of young men
under 30 after mrna vaccinations
in the case of the adenovirus vectored
vaccines we have seen synovenous
thrombosis and thrombosis with
thrombocytopenia syndrome and you can
react to these accordingly
then there are very minimal reactions
which are all recorded in the paul ellis
institute's safety report
president of the paul ellis institute
thank you thank
do you have questions about covid19 our
science correspondent derek williams is
up to date with the latest research and
analysis just send your questions to
covid producer dw.com
[Music]
this week he answers a question from kim
if new variants are evading immunity how
does getting another booster help
with different healthcare authorities
all over the world making a range of
different recommendations
the whole question of who should get a
second booster and which one they should
get and and when they should get it
that's really so a lot of confusion
so
let's just look at some of the questions
and and the answers and the speculation
um first it's clear that getting a
booster shot doesn't act as an iron-clad
barrier that prevents you from getting
the disease completely
in most of us though it does seem to act
as a pretty good deterrent for at least
a while
by pumping up antibody numbers
but that effect doesn't last forever
i've talked to
an awful lot of people who thought that
they were up to date on their shots but
then came down with covet 19 anyway
but on the bright side evidence from
studies shows that when they do get the
disease
boostered people are less likely to have
a severe case
even if they got the booster shot many
months ago
that indicates that at least some of the
long-term effects that original vaccines
have on the immune system that they seem
to be holding up pretty well
in other words
vaccinated and boosted people are
getting sick because their immune
response
isn't really synced to the newer
fast spreading omicron subvariants that
now
dominate the covet landscape but
as a rule they aren't getting really
sick
because their immune system reacts
faster than if it had to learn about the
pathogen from scratch
so
that's certainly an argument for getting
at least the first booster
but expert opinion is still pretty
divided on whether a second booster shot
makes sense for everyone at least it's a
question that's complicated by the fact
that so many people have been infected
this year as omicron sub-variants
swept across the globe and and what
makes things more complicated still
is the issue of what are called
bivalent shots which are
slated to arrive in some places this
fall
they include a component
that specifically targets those omicron
sub-variants so
many people are choosing to wait for
them
but because we still don't really have
any wide scale data on how well those
tweaked vaccines
will actually work
um health care authorities in many
places are trying to strike what seems
to me
to be a safe balance
they recommend a second booster with
current vaccines
for seniors and vulnerable groups if
it's been several months
since the first booster because
especially for those people
every extra bit of immune protection
helps particularly with winter looming
in the northern hemisphere
[Music]
another campaign to get people
vaccinated is starting in spain this
fall
around half of all spaniards have
already received their first booster
shot vaccination rates are high in the
country 85 percent of people have been
vaccinated at least twice
with one of europe's highest vaccination
rates spain eased its covert 19
restrictions last march
those who tested positive no longer had
to self-isolate
masks became mandatory only in health
care settings and on public transport
only the over 60s the immunocompromised
pregnant women and health workers are
monitored
after two years people in spain returned
to everyday life some welcomed that
personally i'm happy that the situation
has been normalized
because this disease is going to be
staying with us for life
of course we have to be careful
but it's time for us to return to our
daily lives
it's time to treat covert like another
fluke
i think we are all aware that the
disease is there that it hasn't gone
away completely
so we have to be careful when we mix
with others
the relaxation of restrictions in spain
took place when the less aggressive ba2
omicron sub-variant was predominant
this didn't put pressure on the health
system but was it too soon
it was risky in a way
nobody in europe had done it
but with hindsight
if we look at the data now
we see acceptable results in terms of
hospitalization rates
in severe cases in intensive care units
and there was no increase in the
fatality rate
however in june the new omicron
sub-variants ba4 and ba5 more
transmissible than the previous ones
unleashed another wave of infections the
new sub-variants are immune to the
antibodies produced by natural infection
or vaccination so people who have
already been infected can be re-infected
as a result the number of coveted cases
increased and more than 11 000 people
were hospitalized at the beginning of
july
the relaxation of measures together with
the emergence of new sub-variants has
made it easier for the virus to spread
again
there's been a spike of cases among the
general population and in the healthcare
sector
and that's put a strain on the health
system
fortunately it's held up quite well
spain is currently undergoing its eighth
coveted wave but incidents in the over
60s has now dropped to 400 cases per 100
000 people the same rate as before the
lifting of restrictions
hospitalizations have also significantly
decreased the spanish government has
announced that the fourth vaccination
campaign will start in autumn however
the new vaccines have to be adapted to
the latest variants of the virus
experts are also warning that the global
vaccination rate will play an important
role in how the pandemic develops and
that a close eye should be kept on new
mutations
the future of the covert 19 pandemic
will also depend very much on the
overall development in the world
in the sense that the entire world
population has to be vaccinated
if the virus continues to reproduce in
other parts of the world
they'll always be the possibility of
variants that escape the immunity that's
been generated
it is the virus that dictates the route
we have to take
and how we have to react
if the virus becomes more infectious
again
we may have to resort to more drastic
measures limiting free movement
setting capacity limits
or curfews
experts say the situation in spain is
under control for now
and that prevention remains the best
weapon to combat the unpredictable virus
and now our science update the covert
studies making headlines
so you had covet 19 and have felt
fatigued or short of breath ever since
for weeks maybe even months
it's probably already occurred to you
that those are classic signs of long
covet
but maybe you noticed other symptoms as
well like that you're losing a lot of
hair or that your sex life is suffering
according to this study those can also
be symptoms of long covet and they occur
a lot more often than you might think
for their study the researchers mined a
huge british database they compared
information provided by around half a
million people who tested positive for
covet 19 but weren't hospitalized with
data from close to 2 million people who
had no prior indications of infection
the study's two big goals were a to
determine the most common long-coveted
symptoms and b to pin down who is most
in danger of ending up a long hauler the
researchers identified a total of 62
symptoms that were linked to an
infection with saskov2
among them ones that regularly occurred
in some patients even 12 weeks later
this long list includes a couple of
symptoms that grab your attention
things like reported hair loss
difficulty ejaculating and reduced
libido the researchers also looked at
who was most at risk of having one or
more of the listed symptoms 12 weeks or
longer after the initial infection
the results showed that women are
affected more often than men and that
all factors considered younger people
appear to be more likely to develop long
covert than elderly patients
socioeconomic status also had an impact
as did of course the patient's health
before the infection
the study has helped clarify the
confusion surrounding the wide range of
long-term symptoms reported by people
who suffer from long covet that in turn
can help medical professionals diagnose
the condition with more confidence
and in the long run hopefully develop
better treatments for coping with its
many different debilitating effects
[Music]
doctors worldwide are still working out
how best to treat the symptoms of long
covid in taiwan people are increasingly
turning to traditional chinese medicine
when the symptoms of a covert infection
won't go away herbal preparations can
help
[Music]
huang wei contracted covet 19 one month
ago and he still has difficulty
breathing
i recovered from the initial illness
after about seven days
but now when i ride my bike it's hard to
breathe and i can barely get going
huang is still suffering from the after
effects of the infection
he had to change his lifestyle to help
cope with the symptoms
she just has a more sensual picture
for me modern medicine is more for
urgent treatments
like for eye disease or a cut
i take chinese medicine for chronic
illnesses
and to relieve my symptoms
one of wang's main symptoms was a fever
and he helped himself using traditional
chinese medicine
the traditional herbal remedy called
taiwan chinguan yihao was developed by
the national research institute
it was approved by the authorities in
april when taiwan was confronted with a
new wave of infections
taiwan has been doing research into the
effect of chinese medicine on
coronaviruses for a long time
now it's also doing clinical research
it was found that chinese medicine can
be effective and this attracted
worldwide interest
you can already find a lot of articles
about chinese medicine in prestigious
journals like the new england journal of
medicine or the landsaid
patients in taiwan need a prescription
from a doctor of chinese medicine to get
chinguan yihao and the cost is covered
by state health insurance
chance you see a local epidemiologist
sees the integration of western and
traditional chinese medicine as a
positive development
i think
this time the complementary alternative
medicines
help so much
and particularly they can relieve
symptoms and they can boost the
immunizations
so during the treatment actually from
taiwan experience
they already
become our national gynae
to help the people
for co2 recovery in combination with the
antivirus therapies
from osodox medicine
more than 60 percent of taiwanese people
believe that traditional chinese
medicine helps to boost immunity and
reduces the likelihood of contracting
covert 19 according to one survey
however herbal medicine has only been
used in taiwan for mild covert 19
symptoms and doctors continue to use
modern medicine to treat severe cases
huangwei appreciates the ways
traditional chinese medicine has helped
to alleviate his symptoms
the pandemic he says has fundamentally
changed his mind about traditional
therapies
[Music]
and that's all for this week thanks for
tuning in and see you next time
[Music]